you know I've always had something of a
struggle with that because I I had a lot
of success on country radio years ago
but even then depending on who you would
speak with or who I was talking to I'd
be pegged either as a folk singer or a
folk rocker who is sort of moonlighting
in country and then I talked to someone
else and they'd say well your country
singer why are they putting you in the
folk section and it still goes on you
know so I I'd like to borrow an idea
from a friend of mine who's an artist
and she says you're a slash artists like
what does that mean she goes you know
country / folk / folk rock / pop /
whatever and you know for the purposes
of I guess marketing and you know
categories on iTunes or whatever it is
you know you you can look a few
different places and find me there and
I'm I'm just about the last person who
wants to try to be definitive about
categories because I like to listen to
so many different things and i imagine i
think it's sort of a badge of honor to
sort of float into a lot of different
places
no I don't think that's true I I mean
you can you can talk to Michael Stipe
and he's from down south and he may not
have much of an accent anymore but that
doesn't make him a country artists and
for that matter you know a lot of people
from the south or rural areas and down
there they may have an accent but that
doesn't necessarily make them a country
artist either I and and I mean it's it's
it's it's an interesting topic you know
it's like when Bruce Springsteen for
example we'll put out an acoustic record
that year and variably it will be
nominated in the folk category of the
Grammys or something but the next year
he'll put out a band record and it'll be
in the rock section so what does that
tell you it just says to me that things
are interchangeable
I don't know um maybe they feel that
it's the sentiments are sappy or easy
you know it's like that it's not deep or
something like that some people just
don't like the sound of the pedal steel
guitar or fiddle sort of traditional
instruments of country music you know I
I didn't really know what country music
was until I found myself in Nashville
and signed to a label there but what I
discovered at that time and this was
1987 I felt I found myself that drawn to
these artists that were writing songs
that were just extraordinary people like
Roseanne cash and Lyle Lovett steve
earle guy clark Townes Van Zandt Rodney
Crowell nanci griffith people that were
writing these amazing story songs and
literary songwriting that was just is
moving to me as anything I'd ever heard
in any genre of music and I felt really
drawn to that but I didn't realize that
that at that time sort of that's what
country music was very much about but
everything's cyclical and everything
changes and nowadays I mean I think
contemporary country music there's
different you know factions whatever but
there's someone like an artist like
Taylor Swift who is just as popular sort
of in pop music because she is in in
country music and some people will say
or will argue well it's not country
music she's doing and other people will
argue from the pop side let's not pop
music she's a country artists and again
we can have this conversation over and
over again but it really is just all in
the ears of the listener and what they
connect to and what they don't
well you know I think it always has had
respect from certain quarters I think
this is a wonderful tribute to Hank
Williams and and his contributions to
American culture and music he's you know
towering figure in terms of the history
of country music and certainly the
American Songbook as well I think it's
just something I just thought about from
your last question but I I think
sometimes country music is kind of
looked down upon by certain depending on
sort of your political you know
persuasion it it has been at times you
know co-opted by either you know the the
right or whatever that that that if your
country the idea being that if you're a
fishy on auto country music or
practitioner whatever if your country
music fan then you must have
conservative politics or that sort of
thing and and again that's something
that I would take exception to I I'm not
a conservative and yet I well again not
much anymore perhaps but at the time I
when I was sort of within that world I
felt very comfortable with my politics
in country music